in the west bank hundreds of palestinian
protesters clashed with police in
ramallah
over the death of a prominent critic of
president mahmoud abbas
there's been growing unrest since nizam
banner died in police custody on
thursday
the palestinian authority says it's
investigating the circumstances of the
activists
death
[Applause]
a slogan from the arab spring echoes
across ramallah on the west bank
the people want the fall of the regime
the chanting continues as police move in
trying to break up the demonstration
black-clad groups of men supporting
palestinian president mahmoud abbas
drag off demonstrators and they
themselves become the focus of the
crowd's anger
about perceived government repression
and autocracy
we want the government to resign and
elections so that the people can choose
a government that represents them
one man's death has caused horror and
outrage to flare up in the palestinian
territories
thousands farewelled human rights
activist nizar banat
as his body was carried through the
streets of hebron he died in palestinian
police custody
his family say they beat him with iron
bars
what niza faced was a planned and
organized crime
those who carried it out bear
responsibility
this is who many hold responsible for
bernard's death president abbas
his palestinian authority denies
violating human rights
its leaders say they're investigating
the activist death
but critics say the investigation ought
to be independent of the government
and furious demonstrations like these
indicate
many palestinians don't think the
authority will hold his killers to
account
you